Oprah people want to know what is your  morning routine usually before the Sun  comes up I offer myself to something  greater than myself  if it's for one minute 20 seconds or 10  minutes I at least stop in that space in  my house every morning I have a little  meditation space where I just go I have  beautiful spiritual readings there I  like my three candles there daily word  or something and I express to this  greater energy feel than I that I don't  want to be alone as I move out into the  world thank you guys so much for  watching this video I hope you enjoyed  if you did let me know in the comments  give it a thumbs up we're still trying  to decide if we continue this series or  not so let your voice be heard leave it  in the comments thank you guys so much  for watching  continue to believe and I'll see you  soon